problème de l'immigration devient
crucial dans certaines régions de france
et notamment tout autour de paris c'est
ainsi qu'un certain nombre de maires de
la seine saint denis estime atteinte la
côte d' alerte c'est le cas à ivry nous
revient à un doublé ce qui qui a
rencontré une responsable du service
logement
celle ci fait d'abord et à des réactions
du public français de souche
ils sont montrés mécontents bien sûr ils
nous accusent de plus souvent de reloger
les immigrés plutôt que et on entend en
tout cas si j'étais portugais si j'avais
la peau noire si j'étais algérien
évidemment j'espère le gie tout de suite
comment interpréter cette réaction
racisme pur refus de l'autre non ce
serait plutôt cette exaspération appelé
communément ras-le-bol elle survient
lorsque la concentration d'étrangers est
trop grande
nord-africains africains de race
religion souvent différentes s'intègre
mal vulnérables quine organisé on les
place on les déplace là où les besoins
se font sentir
dunkerque fos-sur-mer région parisienne
aussi plus de 55 ans sont des salariés
de l'automobile
64% des manoeuvres sont des étrangers
ils doivent se loger
alors ils se concentrent dans les
régions industrielles ils cherchent un
logement économique à la périphérie des
villes
les cités dortoirs souvent gérés par les
municipalités communistes inquiété par
cet afflux d'étrangers
certains élus locaux ont décidé de
réagir
ce qui est posé c'est que soit réalisée
une véritable répartition de
l'immigration entre toutes les villes
il est absolument impossible de penser
khairi l'immigration atteindrait atteint
2 22%
par contre qu'à une ville comme
charenton à côté elle ne soit que lui
pour cent volonté de limiter le nombre
d'immigrés dans la commune pour des
raisons sociales et économiques
ou bien pour réduire ce que certains
appellent des taux n'est ce pas en fait
du racisme tout au moins de l'égoïsme le
racisme constituerait à accepter ces
ghettos le ghetto est toujours un
endroit où il fait il ne fait pas bon
vivre et par conséquent
nous pensons que c'est une continuité de
notre lutte contre le racisme que nous
luttons contre la constitution des
ghettos lorsqu'une famille français
s'installent ici c'est qu'elle n'a pas
l'alternative pour des raisons
économiques des problèmes familiaux se
greffent souvent aux soucis financiers
la scolarité des enfants demanderait
alors des soins attentifs qu'on ne peut
fournir venant s'ajouter à ces familles
là les enfants qui arrivent dont les
familles arrivent et qui ont
automatiquement des problèmes à régler
et bien c'est très difficile et en plus
un tel pourcentage permet difficilement
aux enfants qui arrivent de s'intégrer
facilement dans l'école parfois les
minoritaires ce sont paul étrangers mais
les français cette extrême est atteint
dans certains quartiers d'aulnay en
seine saint denis par exemple 80% de la
population et immigrés on assiste alors
à des situations paradoxales chez les
commerçants par exemple un chat tiff et
puis l'accueil en quatre ans y en a plus
alors que l'arabe l'algérienne tunisien
lenoir a dû s'y propre commerce vous
avez au marché vous avez des commerçants
l'arabe dix commerçants lois qui font
déjà fait avec m en france et en europe
il en plus cuisante et avec la crise la
france découvre un million cinq cent
mille travailleurs étrangers population
encombrante aujourd'hui elle a potent
contribuer à la prospérité du pays